my name is Rob puke father of fuzzy
journalism Wacka Wacka recently I've
been invited to a convention or a con if
you will in Tampa Florida simply known
as shadow con my contact is a young man
named Eagle Raptor I look forward to
meeting such a man who gives himself
such an odd identity they told me that
I'm supposed to have a panel with this
egoraptor apparently me and him are very
popular with the people of Florida god
bless them and help them no I've never
been to a con before and I'm guessing
there's just as boring as most
conventions are so to make things more
interesting I made myself a Pearl Harbor
brownie for those not in the know a
Pearl Harbor brownie is just like any
other brownie except it contains these
essential ingredients it will create
visuals unlike anything outside of a
Lady Gaga concert
Oh operator give me some circus peanuts
and a midget hello I have no idea what
to expect in my state but luckily I came
heavily-armed this would be a convention
unlike any other a normal boring
everyday convention that was about to
experience the harsh reality an epic
strangeness that is Fozzie journalism
let us hope that they will be ready
she's ready a good dysfunctional Tetris
character
don't touch me cancer
no you're gonna get it from those no no
I'm gonna live forever until I shoot
myself okay take this don't sound like
you need it but claim to grow to
nectarine well what's the original think
it's my easier know how to give him some
kind of rampage okay
untamed an atom challenged run late the
sunset cease to fire you belong oh my
god these are hallucinations just deal
with my god how many women you get what
that thing was like hashtag porn new P
of the Arctic
Oh God let's cosplay ever right there
you're gonna do what to me that's not
legal
are you sad
I found Waldo look at unbelievable
I admire your work man your ability to
avoid the CIA is just unbelievable
nobody can find it that's available to
fight for equal rights for every 400 so
your breasts is trying to eat me my god
these drugs are working island pristine
anytime soon I can tell you right now is
that easy button good I could use that
right now no you're all still here
operation see you give her that thing
with your circumcisions are very precise
I betcha I found prints hi guys I love
doing Purple Rain you're on the State
Farm Insurance look at that it's
unbelievable do you have any time out
Hey oh my god is the prince and princess
in the frog
what's going on
and seeing a pet owner
but I think that people here a little
freaky that's some right there
keep up the good fight we're winning
shoot off precise with your familiar
with you Oh what's your name no no no
look listen here young lady
I know who Igor after is he's a tall guy
he does a lot of things if you do boy
sis
don't worry this just because you're
flat just another it's a brownie man is
fucking brownie I'm tongue it gone
straight to my head straight to my that
shit I love brownies now
I don't know if you like this rally
I'll help
price freak
okay
it will say do you see
two thighs are giant pencil pointing
above me reality is coming up is it
going to erase me don't resist don't
resist Lenin or you might see choice
it tastes like music it tastes like Bob
Dylan okay cap appointment is not the
answer
sometimes it is but it's not here yes to
a brighter future
yes I need to draw my future you in a
race yes what keeps calling me oh my god
where are you I'm right in front of you
God trust you because you ignorant press
I have been your friend forever mr.
president
you are funny
starting to make sense well this problem
was solved there was still the issue of
our upcoming panel together
oh hello and welcome to our panel
we're doing duck hunt yes I was